we had a package arrived yesterday from
the Boswell book company and this is
something that I have been looking
forward to getting my hands on for quite
a while I do need it for my research and
for a class that I'm teaching and I'll
show you what it is in just a moment
before that let me tell you a little bit
about Boswell and why we we ordered from
them so Boswell's is a long-standing
local book company here in Milwaukee you
can actually order through them
nationwide so I suggest you go and take
a look at their website and they not
only are a book seller they're also a
place that authors pop in when they're
doing signings and tours and talks
I actually was there just last year with
a talk with with Veronica Roth who some
of you may know from the divergent
series that's a great place it's an
institution here in Milwaukee so I
needed the book that's hopefully
contained in here for the class that I'm
teaching it for two different
institutions ethics and this book
contains Cicero's great classic work of
analysis on friendship which builds off
of Aristotle's discussions of friendship
in the Nicomachean and you Damien ethics
and other places and then incorporates a
lot of other wisdom that Cicero has come
across and his experiences and the
reason we ordered from Boswell was in in
part sort of pragmatic we needed the
book sooner than Amazon could get it to
us and then we thought well actually you
know it's a good idea to support our
local booksellers particularly in this
time when people can't get in and out of
the store so we ordered it from them and
here it is let's see what we've actually
got inside here I hope it is the book
not then this will be in the blooper
roll one sentence so we got an invoice
and here we go
indeed the Loeb classical library on old
age on friendship which I need and it's
also got another important text in here
on divination and you might say well why
is this so important well let me show
you something these are my current
Cicero stacks of the lobes and you know
I don't have everything that they they
put out there's there's quite a few
things that I don't have but you know
these are some of the ones that I used
in my work the rhetorical works des
invents Vionnet de oratory and then the
the paradox
you know stoic paradoxes and then we
have as well his legal or you could say
political theory works on the Republic
on the laws then we have all of these
things that fit in really importantly in
stoicism and also his studies of
epicureanism skepticism Aristotelian ISM
on the ends the Tusculum dissertations
on Duty's on the nature of the gods and
the academics so adding this to it
really helps to round out my library I
don't have everything by Cicero but I've
got quite a bit and you notice I'm not a
big fan of the nice book jackets that
they do in fact provide I prefer not to
have those so this is what this book
looks like in mint condition
many of mine are not quite in mint
condition anymore because they get a lot
of wear and tear and this one is going
to as well over time but the other thing
I really like about the Loeb is that as
you can see here it's got the English on
one side and then the original language
on the other side the Loeb read copies
are all Latin and the Loeb green copies
which you may have seen me using in some
of my videos for example on Aristotle or
epictetus those have the Greek on the
face
Paige and sometimes they actually have
you know critical apparatus some useful
footnotes here and there some references
and so you know the lobes are really
quite nice to have there they are my
preferred book to use there there are
more scholarly editions you could say if
you're like really really high up in in
you know classical scholarship or if you
were you know thirty years ago you'd
look at these is a little bit of
cheating because it's got the English
translation right but for for the
purposes of what I'm doing
they're just excellent and if you ever
go to like classical conferences or you
go to philosophy or political science
conferences where people are talking
about ancient philosophy you'll see
these stacked up on tables so a little
bit more about this particular volume as
I mentioned on friendship I'm going to
be doing some videos on that so you can
look forward to those on friendship is
one of the great works dealing with the
topic of friendship love affection when
we ought to set boundaries how we ought
to treat friends and cicero gave a lot
thought to that but it's also got the
you know here we go the canto my own
aesthetic to take the on old age so
that's that's another great work to have
I might shoot some stuff on it and we
have the on divination in which Cicero
and his interlaken or his brother are
discussing whether divination or trying
to figure out what the gods are you know
knowing and communicating to us whether
that's all nonsense or not and whether
it's possible to know the future because
if we can know the future that means
that the future is in some way set so on
divination fits in really well with the
the much earlier rather than the shorter
rather and fragmentary work on fate and
so this is going to give me a lot to
work with and it adds very nicely to my
stack of Cicero lobes we got our new
entry right here and at the top and I
think really enough for me to say about
this so once again got it from Boswell
books if you click the show more on this
I'll include a link to them you might
want to check out what you can get
through them because you'd be supporting
a local bookstore here in the Milwaukee
area and they do a lot of really good
work in terms of bringing in authors and
hosting discussions and so it's really a
fine institution and they got me the
book that I need for the work that I now
have to do
you